en este vídeo vamos a aprender sobre la
reflexión o podemos decir que vamos a
reflexionar sobre la reflexión
creo que muchos de nosotros tenemos
cierta idea de qué es pero aprenderemos
sobre esto con mayor exactitud existen
dos tipos de reflexiones todo lo que
refleja está haciendo de una u otra
manera o algo intermedio entonces
tenemos dos tipos de reflexiones y vamos
a dibujarlos
tenemos aquí esta superficie y este tipo
de reflexiones con estamos más
familiarizados cuando trabajamos con
espejos esta es la reflexión especular
digamos que esta es la base de un espejo
un rayo de luz
y cae sobre esta superficie este es el
rayo que cae y este rayo se le llama
rayo incidente vamos a escribirlo aquí
rayo
incidente
no va cayendo el espejo podemos casi
imaginar que este rayo va a rebotar
a salir reflejado así y a este otro a
este rayo reflejado lo llamamos
justamente así rayo reflejado
rayo
reflejado
así que cuando cae este rayo de luz en
el espejo se va a reflejar con otra
dirección y quizá ya haya notado si es
que les gusta jugar con espejos que
podemos ver y más adelante veremos
imágenes para que podamos apreciar mejor
esto y pensar sobre ello cuando se miren
en el espejo
que el ángulo de incidencia si yo fuera
dibujar aquí
vertical que tiene 90 grados con
respecto a la superficie del espejo
el ángulo que se forma entre el rayo y
esta vertical
es el ángulo de incidencia o theta y
ángulo de incidencia y resulta que es el
mismo ángulo que cuando este rayo se
refleja el ángulo que se forma acá entre
la vertical y el rayo reflejado se le
llama ángulo de reflexión y estos dos
van a ser iguales el ángulo de
incidencia es igual al ángulo de
reflexión ésta es una propiedad de los
espejos y se llama reflexión especular y
es lo que experimentamos con todos los
espejos comunes y corrientes eso lo
podemos ver en algunas imágenes que les
voy a mostrar aquí
de fotografías de paisajes
estas son unas imágenes de reflexión
especular
aquí tenemos algo de la luz del sol que
cae en la montaña y que esto en
particular es reflexión difusa pero
luego les explicaré que es reflexión
difusa
lo que sucede es que la luz en la
montaña y en todo esto se va a reflejar
de manera dispersa por eso no vemos la
imagen del sol tal cual en esta montaña
solo vemos esta parte blanca
los rayos blancos que se dispersan por
todas direcciones algunos de ellos van a
caer aquí en el agua
voy a tratar de marcar partes de la
montaña que coincidan con su reflejo por
ejemplo esta parte de aquí
tiene su reflejo acá lo que sucede aquí
es que la luz viene de esta parte de la
montaña y va a caer
en el agua vamos a tratar de dibujarlo
la ruta que siguen estos rayos
o menos así
y de aquí en el agua como esta es una
superficie como espejo es muy suavecita
va a reflejar estos rayos hacia nuestros
ojos de hecho bueno esta línea saldría
de la pantalla pero como no puedo
dibujar eso vamos a imaginar que tenemos
aquí nuestro ojo y que la luz se refleja
aquí hacia nuestros ojos y ya habíamos
dicho que el ángulo de incidencia es
igual al ángulo con el que se refleja
si yo dibujar aquí aunque no se nota por
la perspectiva una línea vertical
que es perpendicular al plano de la
superficie del agua de este lago
más o menos así que no está muy derecho
esta es la superficie del lago
aquí hay un ángulo de 90 grados entre
esta vertical y ésta
el ángulo que se forma entre la vertical
y este rayo incidente este ángulo de
aquí que por la perspectiva se ve
pequeño es nuestro ángulo de incidencia
es el mismo ángulo que existe entre esta
misma vertical y el ángulo y el rayo
reflejado
qué es
r estos dos son iguales
aquí es difícil de apreciar por la
perspectiva pero algo que a mí en
particular me ayuda es si vemos o
regresamos a ver estás
este diagrama de acá
estos ángulos que están con respecto a
la vertical el ángulo de tallin y theta
r también puedo asociarnos con el ángulo
que se forma entre el rayo que incide y
la superficie del espejo en donde está
siendo reflejado este ángulo de acá es
el mismo que el que se forma entre el
rayo reflejado y la superficie este
ángulo también estos dos son iguales son
diferentes a estos de acá pero como esto
es un ángulo de 90 grados la suma de
estos dos es igual a 90 al igual que en
este lado si en este detalle es igual a
teta r éstos ángulos ya que se forman
con la superficie también van a ser
iguales así que podemos ver en nuestra
imagen
a lo mejor se les facilita más
recordarlo de este modo
que el ángulo
de incidencia que se forma entre este
rayo y la base la superficie
este ángulo de incidencia es igual al
ángulo del rayo reflejado que se forma
aquí entre este rayo y la superficie
y esto también lo podemos ver en esta
otra imagen de acá la luz del sol cae
directamente en el agua esta luz del sol
por ejemplo
vaca es
en este punto en el agua y de aquí se va
a reflejar hacia nosotros si imaginamos
que aquí está nuestra vista a nuestro
ojo
baa
es el rayo de luz de este punto y ya sea
que digamos que el ángulo de que se
forma con el rayo incidente con respecto
a la superficie aquí voy a dibujar la
superficie de este lago más o menos así
el plano de la superficie ya sea que el
ángulo imaginemos que se forma entre el
rayo que incide y la superficie este
ángulo
o si imaginamos una línea vertical
perpendicular a la superficie
o menos así
y el ángulo que se forma entre este rayo
incidente y esta vertical va a ser igual
al ángulo reflejado si es en este caso
el ángulo incidente de tallin va a ser
igual a el ángulo que se forma acá
r oh si lo vemos con respecto de la
perpendicular
este ángulo que se forma aquí te está y
va a ser igual al ángulo que se forma
entre esta vertical y el rayo reflejado
nuevamente es difícil de apreciar debido
a la perspectiva pero espero que con
esto comience a tener sentido lo que es
la reflexión especular los invito a que
se acerquen a su espejo más cercano y
ponga el objeto cerca de él y piensen
analicen cuál es el ángulo que tiene la
luz del objeto al llegar al espejo para
que pueda llegar hasta sus ojos
ahora todo lo que hemos visto hasta el
momento sobre reflexión especular
regresamos a nuestro diagrama original
entonces tenemos esto que hablamos sobre
la reflexión especular ahora vamos a
hablar del segundo tipo de reflexión que
es la reflexión difusa y este es un tipo
de reflexión que puede no ser obvia para
nosotros pero que realmente ocurre por
todas partes en donde podamos ver
entonces aquí anotamos esto que hablamos
es reflexión ésta es especular
de espejos
especular y esta que vamos a mencionar
ahora explicar es la reflexión difusa
y en este caso debido a que la
superficie no va a ser suave y plana la
superficie aquí va a ser muy diferente a
la que asociamos con un espejo
esta va a ser una de superficie rugosa y
hago hincapié en que en la reflexión
especular el ángulo de incidencia de
cualquier rayo siempre va a ser igual al
ángulo reflejado si yo tengo un rayo que
cae acá
va a tener el mismo ángulo de reflexión
si pongo un rayo o este rayo cae más
verticalmente su reflejo será también
más con un ángulo más agudo
la reflexión difusa ocurren muchas cosas
locas porque no tenemos una superficie
plana y suave las moléculas que forman
esa superficie hacen cosas locas con la
luz que cae si por ejemplo cae un rayo
aquí
zonas por acá podría reflejarse
así
cae otro rayo con el mismo ángulo que
este original pero cae en otra parte el
reflejo a lo mejor sale así
y cae otro rayo igual con el mismo
ángulo que los anteriores que mencioné
pero cae aquí a lo mejor en esta parte
se refleja así
todos los ángulos de reflejos pueden ser
diferentes a los ángulos con los que
entró el rayo de luz
la idea general con la reflexión difusa
es que los rayos reflejados giran a
todas direcciones
locas todas mezcladas se dispersan estos
rayos imaginen que aquí tenemos una
imagen del sol
no voy a dibujar el sol pero vamos a
imaginar que estos rayos de aquí vienen
del sol
así que van a caer todos más o menos con
el mismo de hecho lo más o menos van a
quedar exactamente con el mismo ángulo
si estamos en esta superficie
especular o de espejo cada uno de estos
rayos va a rebotar y va a conservar el
mismo ángulo es decir la información de
la imagen con la que llega va a
conservarse y podemos ver la imagen en
el reflejo
en cambio aquí en la luz difusa si cada
uno de estos rollitos blancos que dibujé
son rayos que vienen del sol de una
imagen del sol
pues van a salir por todos lados se van
a dispersar aunque se conserve la luz la
información que traen estos rayos como
imagen se va a perder porque se va a
dispersar
si ustedes se preguntan en donde ocurre
la reflexión difusa basta con que miren
a su alrededor todo lo que no sea un
espejo va a reflejar la luz difusa mente
y lo podemos ver aquí en estas fotos se
los voy a volver a mostrar aquí en esta
montaña hay reflexión difusa los rayos
del sol de la luz del sol van a caer con
el mismo ángulo aquí
pero como esta es una superficie rugosa
pues van a rebotar por todas las partes
esta luz blanca
por lo que no vamos a ver un reflejo del
sol en la montaña en cambio en el agua
tenemos reflexión especular ya que la
superficie es tan suave que los ángulos
de incidencia y de reflexión siempre se
conservan son iguales y podemos ver una
imagen completa
en los árboles también tenemos reflexión
y difusa pero no sólo eso cualquier cosa
que no sea blanca y recordemos que la
luz del sol es blanca y el blanco el
color blanco está compuesto de todos los
colores así que en el caso de los
árboles debido a la fotosíntesis van a
absorber todos los tipos o frecuencias
de luz excepto las verdes y es por eso
que aunque aquí también cae luz blanca
los árboles van a reflejar o no van a
absorber luz verde y es por eso que lo
hacemos de color verde
vamos a terminar el vídeo con algo
interesante es esta imagen que tenemos
aquí
en donde vemos que está el cielo
reflejado en el agua y a su vez este
reflejo del agua se encuentra aquí en
este remo este remo de metal pulido
y se ve como un espejo
y aquí tenemos un juego de billar de la
luz tenemos lo que es
la luz del sol que voy a dibujar aquí
que se refleja en el agua que a su vez
del agua se va a reflejar
en el remo y del remo va a nuestros ojos
así que aquí tenemos un doble reflejo
nuevamente el ángulo de incidencia en
todas estas situaciones aquí son iguales
a sus respectivos ángulos reflejados
aunque en el remo y un poco de
distorsión así que las matemáticas aquí
son un poquito diferentes
esto se vuelve muy interesante observar
todas las superficies reflejantes y
tratar de observar estos ángulos de la
luz